hey everybody rob greenfield here and
today i'm going to talk to you about the
survival garden what i mean by that is a
garden where you don't have to go to the
grocery stores or other restaurants and
you can live off of this it can produce
your calories it can produce your
nutrients and at the very least it can
get you through
weeks or months of not having to go to
the grocery store so this
is the survival garden
[Music]
okay so why would i be the one to talk
to you about the survival garden well
i recently finished a year-long project
of growing and foraging 100 of my food
so for one year
every single thing that i ate either
came from either came from my gardens or
that i foraged from the wild down to the
salt the oil all my calories my
nutrients my protein my fat you name it
so i have quite a bit of experience and
this survival garden that i'm going to
be talking about today is specifically
going to be for where i did this project
which is central florida so this
survival garden is more for a warmer
climate but there's a lot that you'll be
able to learn from this video no matter
where you are and most importantly
wherever you are you can grow an
incredible amount of food it's just a
matter of adapting to the correct plants
that are designed to not just survive
but thrive in your area
so i'm going to start off right away
with calories
number one i'm going to share sweet
potatoes sweet potatoes are a truly
amazing crop a lot of us know sweet
potatoes for the the potato itself
but what a lot of people don't realize
is that the greens are edible as well
between the nutritious greens and the
calorie dense tubers they're one of the
most important crops that can be grown
as far as putting out an incredible
amount of calories and nutrients
i
probably grew 600 pounds of sweet
potatoes in my year of growing and
foraging all my food and i'm just blown
away at how much you can grow now a lot
of people imagine these little orange
ones at the grocery store but they come
in all shapes and sizes i've seen sweet
potatoes that are up to 13 pounds
and i've been blown away at how much
sweet potatoes you can grow in a
relatively small amount of space in a
standard front yard
it's possible to grow all of your
calories let me say that again it is
possible in a standard front yard to
grow all the calories you need with
different tuber crops
so
the second one that i'm going to talk
about is called cassava or yucca
and for those of you who still haven't
heard either of those words it is what
tapioca is made out of so this is the
true survival food over a billion people
around the world depend on it for their
very survival
it's twice as calorie dense as sweet
potatoes at about 700 calories per pound
is what i've read
so it is truly truly calorie dense a
couple pounds of this per day
meets your calorie needs that said it
doesn't have a lot of nutrients but
we'll get into the nutrient crops soon
so the beautiful thing about
cassava is you literally just take a
stick of it a branch you take that
branch you stick it into the ground
come back 12 months later and you've got
yourself a whole
cassava tree or bush or whatever you
want to call it with the tuber under the
ground
you don't plant it like a potato
you plant it with
with a little cutting basically
and you can actually eat the leaves as
well now cassava or yucca has
cyanide in it but a lot of foods have
cyanide in it and it's just a matter of
cooking it the right way again a billion
people live on this around the world so
you just have to cook it
so that's yucca or cassava one plant can
put out 10 20 pounds of tubers from one
plant
and the average one that i've gotten in
central florida is probably around five
to ten pounds of tubers so
that is cassava or yucca that's number
two number three is another really
really great tuber another calorie dense
crop and that is yams the genus and
species
that i've worked with is
diascoria a lotta if that's how you
pronounce it and in florida this has
actually become invasive it is made out
of cultivation i believe it's originally
from asia
possibly africa too
and it's a commonly grown crop for many
people around the world
now when i say yam
a lot of people think of the
per of the sorry the
the orange ones that you get at the
grocery store which we call sweet
potatoes and yams interchangeably no a
yam the largest one that i've ever
harvested was 150
pounds imagine
i weigh about 150 155 pounds
the one i harvested the biggest one was
pounds so the size of me they get
massive
an average one might be 10 20 30 pounds
is not abnormal
and the beautiful thing about all three
of these first crops is that most of
them you can largely set it set them and
forget them especially
yucca and cassava those are drought
tolerant they don't need a lot of
nutrients and 12 months later you come
back and you can have a whole survival
garden you can do your fence around your
property all with yucca and yams and
just have a
living
fence of
serious calories to be able to come back
to when it's needed or
just when it's desired but back to the
big yam the average one 10 20 30 pounds
they're delicious
i actually prefer them over potatoes
and they are a
vining species
not an edible leaf
unlike the yucca and the sweet potato
both of those have edible leaves
but uh this is a just another beautiful
calorie crop now another calorie crop
that i want to mention is potatoes the
crops that i'm talking about are a
little bit more for the warmer climates
although sweet potato is something
that's grown throughout
but potatoes are a standard that can be
grown all across many climates it's not
one that i have a lot of experience with
i have grown it
in florida but that is a really
wonderful crop that you can grow in huge
volumes as your calorie so those are
four calorie crops and the next one i
want to get into is indeed a calorie but
it's also a delicious fruit and a
favorite food of many people around the
world and that is bananas and i'm also
going to talk about plantains bananas
are a true survival food you can take
one bananas by the way they you can't
you don't plant them from seeds you
plant them from a pup which is basically
a small plant how bananas work is they
send up
uh babies or pups um little shoots out
the sides and you can get if you have a
if there's a huge stand of bananas you
can just dig one of those up with part
of the corn plant it in a few years and
in a few years time you can have a whole
stand of bananas
so bananas in
central florida where i did my year for
example
within about 12 months they can be
starting to produce within a few years
you can be talking about huge quantities
of bananas and plantains
now bananas can be eaten
green
fried for example or you can wait until
they're ripe and you can eat them as a
delicious banana you can also actually
dehydrate the skin and the banana whole
and dehydrate it and then blend it to
make a flower and then of course
plantains are a staple of many many many
people all over the world those can be
eaten
ripe as a as a delicious
sweeter flavor or they can be eaten
savory when they are still green
so that is the banana
you can grow
hundreds and hundreds of pounds of
bananas you can start it with something
that you can get for 10 or 20 dollars or
for free
the next one that i want to go into is
papaya and papaya is extremely versatile
papaya is a tree but it's not your
typical tree they will last generally
about
at maximum seven years
three to five years might be pretty
normal and they're a very soft tree you
could basically push them over you can
you can cut down the papaya tree just
with the
one swipe
of a machete
but the fruit is a beautiful fruit and
it's very versatile so of course you can
wait until it's ripe and
you can
then it's in a nice sweet orange
or you can eat it while it's green more
as a vegetable and i make sort of like a
sauerkraut with it
a papaya kraut by fermenting it and then
people all over the world use it green
as a vegetable
whether pickled or sauteed or
raw
what's commonly known is thai green
papaya salad for example and i love to
make a coconut curry out of my green
papayas
if you're dealing with wasps a pest that
often comes for the papayas then the
best thing to do is not wait for them to
get ripe and eat them green
so this is a great staple crop not as
calorie dense as the earlier calories
calories i mentioned but very filling
and very
much has calories to it now in a colder
climate something that actually somewhat
resembles in my mind the papaya
is the zucchini
zucchini in a colder climate is a true
survival crop i hear stories all the
time about people saying that in the
northern climates
they have so many zucchinis that they
have to put them on their neighbors
doors to try to get rid of them but
their neighbors hide from them because
they don't want them because they have
so many and the reason i'm i'm it
reminds me
of papayas because they can grow very
large and in extreme abundance and they
and they can be cooked in a in a similar
manner
and they don't again have an incredible
amount of calories but they have a large
amount of sustenance and can really fill
you up so that's the papaya and for some
people the zucchini and speaking of
zucchini what i have to mention for the
survival garden that i'm talking about
is
a heat loving a heat tolerant squash and
for me that is the seminal pumpkin
it's amazing what you can do with one
seed most people with their pumpkins and
with their squash when they buy them at
the grocery store what do they do they
take those seeds out and they throw them
in the garbage at the very least you
could compost them but what you can
actually do
is plant them especially if they're a
local variety
when i had dinner with a friend i had
i took home the pumpkin seeds from
seminal pumpkins and from two pumpkins
the seeds of that turned into hundreds
of pumpkins
many many many meals to come the seminal
pumpkin is my favorite pumpkin
personally my favorite squash wherever
you are your survival garden can
definitely include squashes
the next thing that i want to move on to
is talking about a little bit of protein
and for me one of my favorite sources in
the garden is pigeon pea now pigeon pea
is a perennial crop it's not a bean that
has to be planted
year after year
it's actually a tree that will continue
to put out pigeon peas
and sometimes multiple times per year
and even throughout the year they're a
truly delicious they're they're called
gandules they're very popular in puerto
rico and other parts of the caribbean
other parts of latin america as well and
they are truly truly delicious i've
eaten
a large amount of them and have never
once got sick from them at all and in
fact my friend and i actually even made
tempeh from them
so there's a lot that they can be done
that can be done with them so that is
pigeon peas and along those lines the
next one i want to talk about is ground
cover
beans or peas and for me my favorite one
is the southern peas now there's many
types of southern peas you've probably
heard of black eyed peas for example
there's many different types of these
and i don't know the names of all of
them but we're talking about spreading
the seed
on the ground it creates a wonderful
ground cover
and it produces a lot of healthy food it
can also be used as a cover crop and as
a nitrogen fixer to add nitrogen to your
to your garden now these can be in fresh
or they can be left to dry on the vines
harvested once they're dry and they can
be stored and the same goes for the
pigeon peas as well so talking about
survival
these are foods that when dried you can
have these lasting in your pantry for
years and that's an important part about
this is storage now in the
warmer climates like florida for example
you can grow food year around
in the northern climates the key to
success with the survival garden
is producing as much food as you can
during that window of time that you have
and then preserving it for the fall now
for all the people out there who are
saying oh you can only do this in
florida
i have to say these most extreme
abundance that i've ever seen was in the
fall
in places like northern wisconsin where
i'm from
the abundance of nuts and
different fruits like apples and plums
and pears and berries is on it's
incredible so much more than i've than
i've ever seen
in some warmer climates so you just have
to work with your area so those are a
few
examples of protein we've covered
calories
we've covered some protein
and now i want to get into some of the
very nutrient dense foods
and the really good news is that a lot
of these nutrient-dense foods whether
you want to be
self-sufficient and being able to exist
without a grocery store or restaurant at
all
these nutrient dense foods are a
no-brainer for everyone because they
take very little work
they can save a lot of money they're
some of the healthiest foods out there
that you can eat
and environmentally they're one of the
most logical things to grow at home
because shipping greens
is one of the least efficient things
that we can ship
so i'm going to talk about perennial
greens
and the first one that i'm going to talk
about is moringa now moringa is also
called the vitamin tree or the tree of
life and it is truly the tree of life
it's one of the most nutrient dense
plants on earth supposedly it's about 20
percent
protein by weight as well so a lot of
greens can have a lot of greens and
vegetables actually do have a lot of
protein in them as well
moringa is a perennial you can start it
either from seed or you can take a
cutting stick it in the ground and have
a moringa tree you can make
a wall around your property with moringa
you can dry moringa leaves turn it into
a powder and you have your own
multi-vitamin that you can travel with
and it's also a really great crop that
you can trade you can trade others this
this nutrient-dense powder that you make
for other things that you need or you
can actually make a little business out
of it and sell it
the next green that i want to talk about
is katuk katuka is another perennial
green and by perennial what i mean is
you plant it and it produces year after
year after year
up in a northern climate a beautiful
perennial is rhubarb an average rhubarb
plant can last for 25 years imagine you
plant it in 25 years every spring it
just keeps coming back
annuals you plant once for example
carrots and then when you pull it you
eat it and it's dead and then in between
perennials and annuals is self-seeding
annuals and these are ones that you let
go to seed and they keep spreading their
seed and they just keep coming back once
you got them going you've got them going
so in the survival garden i highly
recommend working with perennials and
self seating annuals as much as possible
so i mentioned katuk and the next one
that i want to
talk about is chaya chaya is an ancient
food it's been eaten for thousands of
years um i don't remember if it's the
the mayans or the aztecs or possibly
both
that have had it as a staple part of
their diet
it is
also called tree spinach
and very calorie dense this one also has
to be cooked because it has cyanide in
it just like i mentioned with the
cassava or the yucca but again
it's just a matter of preparing food
right
all things have to be prepared right
whether it's coffee or chocolate or the
way you're producing your
your your beverages like beer and wine
you'll once you start to connect with
your food your food you see that there
is a process a way of doing things
but chaya is a beautiful one this is one
where you can literally just take a
stick of it put it in the ground
and after you have a few trees of chaya
you can be spreading chaya to your
entire neighborhood
another one that's very drought tolerant
and with the survival garden the key is
planting things
that are very
very tough that don't need to be
consistently watered that don't need a
lot of nutrients that don't have too
many pests and all of these things apply
generally to perennials over annuals so
the survival garden is one that you can
walk away from and for three months
later you come back and your food isn't
gone you have more food than when you
left
so that is chaya the next thing i want
to get into is another greens and that
is perennial spinaches so there's all
sorts of perennial spinaches there's
brazilian spinach and new zealand
spinach okinawa spinach longevity
spinach just to name a few malabar
spinach is another one
there's probably a good dozen or so that
are grown in the area where i have done
most of my growing and again these are
perennials that you can plant once and
they can keep on coming back and coming
back so with those perennial spinaches
and those and the chaya the cassava fl
leaves
the
katuk and the moringa that right there
is quite a bit of diversity in itself so
there is a saying and that is let thy
food be thy medicine and let thy
medicine be thy food now in 2020 that is
let your food be your medicine and let
your medicine be your food pretty basic
now the beautiful thing is that yes our
food is our medicine
but there are some acts and some
especially medicinal plants that we can
grow to really
give ourselves that that important
immune boost and to really just take
care of ourselves i'm talking about
holistic medicine holistic health care
taking into account everything that
we're doing the our food our water the
way we move our body the way we live our
life the way we live our lives but we
can grow a lot of our own medicine
the number one that i recommend in this
survival garden is turmeric and ginger
turmeric you take those little rhizomes
you stick them in the ground and
seven nine months later you'll have a
lot more tumeric most of my friends
gardens who have tumeric they have more
than they can deal with
ginger
is it takes a little bit longer it takes
more like i think about a year and a
half i've successfully grown ginger
but it takes longer to get it
to be a large amount and to to get a lot
to harvest but very very easy to grow so
turmeric and ginger
very easy to grow
and
very very important medicines there's
many different medicines one that i
recommend growing is elderberry and
along with honey that you can get you
from your bees you can make elderberry
syrup and this is one of them one of the
most incredible natural medicines that
prevents cold and flu i like to take a
spoonful of my elderberry syrup every
single day it's one of my favorite
things and it's also an extremely
delicious treat
so i've covered calories i've covered
some protein and i've covered greens as
nutrients those three things right there
can take care of a massive
massive amount of your entire
needs
you could probably live just off of that
but there's no need to because there's
such an abundance of other foods i'm
going to name a few other things right
now that are really easy and important
to have as a part of this garden that
would be peppers i grew serrano peppers
starting from one seed from a pepper
from my friend's garden i for a year and
a half had a serrano pepper plant that
put out well over a thousand peppers
wherever you are there are peppers that
will survive and
thrive
peppers are a great part of any garden
and then herbs herbs to add flavor to
your food
living off of your garden does not in
any way mean not eating delicious
delicious food and in fact it's often
far more delicious so some of the
absolute survival herbs that i've grown
that would be cuban oregano grows like
crazy it's a huge oregano leaf
then there's lots of other ones
african blue basil grows into shrubs
brings in an incredible amount of bees
and pollinators so important to have
different plants that can bring in
pollinators into your garden
and herbs are one of the easiest things
to grow you have cilantro and basil and
dill just to name a few herbs are a very
easy beginner plant too if you're just
getting started herbs are a really great
place to start i'm going to mention just
two more even though there's so many
more plants that i would love to talk
about but a truly amazing one is daikon
radish we're talking about a radish that
can get
this big that can become self-seeding
that's coming back that creates a great
ground cover that can be chopped and
dropped and
you can you can ferment this and make a
wonderful
radish kraut or mix it in with with your
different krauts it is a
it's delicious it adds a lot of value to
meals and you can just produce
incredible amount of quantities with it
that's the daikon radish wherever you
are
radishes can be a part of your game and
radishes are one of the fastest foods to
grow you can get them in about 30 days
now a garden could be complete without
tomatoes but tomatoes add such an
incredible value to life where i
did my survival garden that would be the
everglades tomato in really hot climates
it's often the very small tomatoes that
you want to work with not the really big
ones but in northern climates you can
produce so much tomatoes that you could
not possibly
eat them so tomatoes are just a
beautiful beautiful thing to have in the
garden and then one last thing that i'm
going to mention and that is garlic or
onions really adds an incredible amount
of flavor garlic is also a great
antimicrobial and antibacterial a really
important one for fighting off
sicknesses
in central florida my big ones would be
garlic chives and then society garlic
these are perennials that do really well
i also grew
garlic that's harder in the southern
climates but i did it successfully but
in the northern climates garlic is an
easy one
so
that is my survival garden i've covered
your calories your protein your greens
there are more things than that however
this if you have just this going and you
work with the perennials over the
annuals we're talking about almost never
having to take a trip to the grocery
store this is
my tips especially
focused on
a warmer climate in future videos i will
have some that are specifically focused
on colder climates so make sure you come
back and tune in for that
and if you got a lot out of this video
and you found it to be really useful
then definitely i encourage you to
subscribe to this channel and if you
have questions or comments put them
below hit that like button to make this
get out into the world so people can see
that it is possible
to live without grocery stores and
without restaurants and live in a way
where we are working with the earth
rather than against it and where we can
live happily and healthfully
with food sovereignty right in our own
communities love you all very much see
you soon
[Music]